les enfants venaient les city ont dansé
un peu hagard
agathe sylvie venir dans des combats ou
va-t-elle l'attendait vous connaissez 1
2 ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap par mon
papa me viens viens et d'acteurs essayé
tous les deux
tu as compris de papa me parlait pas pas
mon papa pam pam ou papam padam padam
padam padam padam padam padam padam
padam padam padam padam alors ça ça vous
a plu
un bond à écouter il faut que j'aille
voir ton choix vous jouer je reviens
tout à l'heure un ouais je cherchais
j'ai une lettre pour toi pour moi oui
elle vient de loin tu sais allez au
revoir merci à l'auteur des acteurs doit
bien continuer ma tournée pendant les
essais réalisés aller julie
oui je voudrais bien mourir ma lettre je
ne voudrais pas abîmer le timbre ben oui
mais il faut que je trouve un couteau
alors çà ou là mais j'ai de la chance à
attends tu permets que cela des pour les
bien merci
c'est une langue d'oc de ma tante
adélaïde je reconnais son écriture
presse
mon cher qu'à venir j'ai reçu des
nouvelles de toit par ta cousine
gertrude
tu sais que les murs ont des oreilles
s'il est quasi me russes n'en n'ont pas
suis bien mes conseils ce sont les
petites pluies qui gâte les banques
semaine la fin chasse le loup du bois
faute de grives on mange des merles
comme on fait son lit on se couche
je t'embrasse ta tante adélaïde en soir
je ne comprends rien le très mystérieux
tu sais pas la même entre la matin au
passé simple
ce sont des proverbes et que tu viens
avec moi jusqu'au banc des proverbes les
enfants enfants nés avec moins rythmée
dans l'air la voit ce qui se passe il ya
casimir qui vient de recevoir une lettre
de sa tante adélaïde y comprend rien à
ce qui lui a écrit alors on va essayer
de l'aider c'est d'accord c'est écrit
avec des proverbes
est ce que vous savez ce que c'est que
les projets agathe agathe de ses parts
et valéry de sète a expliqué tanoh plus
françoise rélévé on exprime
quelque chose qu'on exprime qui nous
montrent ce qui si oui ce des re dans la
vie courante tous les jours on se sert
quelquefois de phrases toutes faites qui
existe depuis très très longtemps pour
exprimer certaines idées un petit
exemple un exemple dans l'allée menant à
la planète exemple justement alors je
vous lis la lettre de la tante adélaïde
à casimir mon cher casimir
j'ai reçu des nouvelles de toit par ta
cousine gertrude
tu sais que les murs ont des oreilles
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça mais voilà
alors que les casimir hussenot papa elle
continue alors tu sais que les murs ont
des oreilles
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça nous
sommes tous les murs entre nous tous
frédéric tu peux compléter j'espère que
chez eux les murs c'est toujours chaud
c'est là-bas alors là ce que ça veut
dire
les murs ont des oreilles dans un
entretien confidentiel
il faut se méfier de tout ce qui nous
entoure voilà comment on continue la
lerm on suit bien mes conseils ce sont
les petites pluies qui gardent les
bronches me voilà un autre fera perdre
qu'est ce que sont les boulangeries qui
gâte les beaux chemins alors naïs agathe
ah ça fait de cet effet ça fait pousser
des fleurs déjà lis ça je pense pas que
ce soit l'explication johanna valérie
elle décidera quelle chienlit que ce
sont les petites pluies qui gardent les
bons chemins sinueux chemin dire que
beaucoup de petites dépenses de rien du
tout à la fin de vienne ruineuse il faut
comprendre un bon je continue la lettre
de la tante adélaïde la soeur chasseloup
du doigt frédéric voilà la bonne
explication dans le bois quand le loup à
feu il sort du bois pour aller chercher
à manger au risque peut-être de se
rattraper par les hommes et se faire
tuer donc la nécessité quelques fois
contre les hommes à faire des choses qui
sont pas tout à fait dans leur cour
voilà c'est une bonne équipe et celle où
on continue tu écoute bien à casimir oui
oui oui alors comme ça que je la
comprends la lettre tante adélaïde
faute de grives on mange des merles ça
je crois que c'est assez facile casimir
lui a rien compris mais ça veut rien
dire c'est comme admettre ni l'un ni
l'autre allant chercher des fautes de
grives on mange des merles michelin
fabrique c'est à dire quand on a
l'habitude de manger par un très bon me
fais d'habitude
gossio n'a simplement un tout petit
morceau de pain on s'en contente le
trias voilà c'est simple c'est ça aulas
je continue comme on fait son lit on se
couche
alors frédéric a compris toi bien comme
on fait son lit on se couche à redire il
faut s'attendre en bien ou en mal à ce
qu on s'est préparé par sa conduite
contre et c'est terminé
je t'embrasse très fort d'attentats de
l'aïd et ben voila je crois casimir tu
peux leur dire merci
malev tante adélaïde vous retourner
jouer
- merci alors qu'elle est meilleure chez
content tu l'as compris la lettre de
l'attentât de la rue enfin les proverbes
j'ai compris mieux compris à l'heure
alors oui alors j'espère que le m'écrire
appli jamais au caire
[Musique]